in a previous video when we were looking
at a very simple case of compounding
interest we got the expression 1 plus 1
over n
1 plus 1 over n
to the nth power and the way we got this
we saw an example where a loan shark is
charging 100 percent interest and that's
where this one is and then if they only
if they only compound once in the year
so it's 100 over the year then n is one
so you get one plus a hundred percent
over one to the first power you're gonna
have to pay back twice the amount the
original amount of money if n is two one
plus one half is one and a half to the
second power gets you 2.25 is if you
compound half if you compound half the
interest so 100 over two but you
compound it twice and then we kept going
and going going we saw interesting
things happen and i want to review that
right over here using this calculator i
want to see what happens as we get
larger and larger and larger ends in
that last video we went as high as n is
equal to 365 and it seemed to be
approaching a magical number but now
let's let's go even further so let's get
let's
let's type in
and let's throw some really large
numbers here one plus
one over let's do a million
one two three one two three so that's a
million
to the
to the millionth power one two three one
one two three did i get the right number
zeros yeah that looks right and before i
even press enter which is exciting let's
just think about what's going on here
this part that we have here as n gets
larger and larger it's getting closer
and closer to one but never quite
exactly one this is one and one
millionth so it's very close to one but
not exactly one and we're going to raise
that thing to the millionth power and
normally when you raise something to the
millionth power that's just going to go
be unbounded just become some huge
number but there's a clue that well with
one to the millionth power would just be
one if we're getting really close to one
well maybe this this won't just be some
unbounded number
and when we calculate it we see that
that's the case so it's
2.71828 and just keeps going now let's
go even higher let's let's take it
let's
let's do
one plus
one
over
over and actually i can now use i can
now use scientific notation let's say
one times 10
to the 7th power so that's literally
this right over here is 10 million
to the
10 millionth power
so what do we get here
so now we went point seven one eight two
eight one six nine two let's go even
larger
so let's get our last entry here so
let's go instead of the seventh power
let's go to the eighth power so now
we're now we're one plus one over a
hundred million to the 100 millionth
power i don't even know if this
calculator can handle this
and we get 2.7182818181487
and you see that we are quickly
approaching or maybe not so quickly we
have to raise this to a very large power
to the number e the number e in our
calculator you see we've already gotten
to we've already gotten one two three
four five six seven digits to the right
of the decimal point by taking it to the
100th millionth power so we are
approaching this number
we are approaching so one way to talk
about it is we could say
the limit
as n approaches infinity
as n becomes larger and larger it's not
becoming unbounded it's not going to
infinity it seems to be approaching this
number and we will call this number we
will call this magical and mystical
number e
we'll call this number e and we see from
our calculator that this number and
these are kind of these are almost as
famous digits as the digits for pi
we get we're getting 2.718
eight
two
eight one
eight and it just keeps going and going
and going never never repeating so it's
an infinite string of digits never never
repeating just like pi pi you remember
is the ratio of the circumference to the
diameter of the circle e is another one
of these crazy numbers that shows up in
the universe and in other videos on khan
academy we go into depth why this is so
magical and mystical already this is
kind of cool that i can take a i can
take an infinite if i just make i just
add one over a number to one and take it
to that number and i make that number
larger and larger and larger it's
approaching this this this number but
what's even crazier about it is we'll
see that this number which you can view
one way of it is coming out of this
contin this compound interest
that number pi
the imaginary unit which is defined as
that imaginary unit squared is a
negative one that they all fit together
in this magical mystical way and we'll
see that again in future videos but just
for the sake of e what you could imagine
what's happening here
is going to our previous example of
borrowing a dollar and and trying to
charge 100 over year that when our n was
one that means you're just charging over
one period when n is two you're charging
over two periods and and then
compounding or you're compounding over
two periods when n is three compounding
over three periods when n approaches
infinity you could view it as your
continuously compounding every zillionth
of a second every every just every
moment you're compounding just a super
small amount of interest but you're
doing it
essentially you're approaching an
infinite number of times and you get to
this number